REPUBLICANS HAVE BECOME R OF STE
AE L WORLD UPAND
LA
STRANGE UNTIL YOU GET THISBIG C.
GEORGIA REPUBLICANS CALLING FO
GIANTS COKE AND I MEAN, THAT'S
THNA PASTIWHREPUBLICANS ARE DOI
R LEAGASE FROM ATLANO
THAT
MSKS TO STAY T OFFTER A CAR T
BUSINESS ADEMNIN
VOGHBEZOS ARE
BACKING PRESIDENT BIDEN'S CALL
FO
SURREAL CA OTHAT?WITH THE
COLECS.
DISCOURAGING TO FIND A BUNCHF O
MY ADVICE TO THE COR CEOs
OF AMERICA IS TOY OUT OF
TS.SIDES? SIDES IN E BIG
F POLITICS
FROM THE GUY WHO SUED OVER
CORPORATIONS' ABILITY TO
ELECTIONS?SU RAISED  R DERS
CONG THE 202TION, SAME GUYBUT NA
CORPORATIONS ARE RESPONDG
EMPLOYEES,TOMERS AND
Y STANDING UP TO  PSEW OF
LIE BECAUSE, AS THE
NEW YORKER
KNOWS THATREFORMS ARE BROADLY PU
EVEN WITH REPUBLICANS.
A LOT OF BUSINESLEN'S CAE INFRA.
PROPOSEYIGELYRAG TH
TE28%.THE WA WOULD STILL
AR'S BEEN
SINCE  WORLD WAR II.
FECOIONSAYATE BECT
WHICH BRINGSTO AN EYE- FROM PRE
BIDEN.
>> Y H O52
RPFO50
>>ANCHECK.
AS IT TURNS  MOSYES.
IN FACT, THERE WERE ATPROFITABLO
0 ANS&0 THATRAL TA02
ATORNGITUTE OFAND  PT
THE
PASTHRT,
26.
BIG BUSINESSES SAYING THEY'RE  ?
HYSTERIA.OGS AND CATS LIVING
ALESSES SEE
VESTMENTS
-TERM
COMPETRE NOT OVER, BUTTILY A
CONSERVATIOP
AND THAT'S YOUR "REALITYHE DOG
THS THROTHE CAMERA EI, YOU KNOWS
CUURUT WHAT FOLK
AUTHENTIC LOVE OF PUNKISR
AND YOU ADD THOSE TWO THINGS
TOGETHER AND YOU REALLY GET ART.
WE LOVE YOU. W
IT IS NOT GOOD-BYE
IT'S JE YOR IN THE
AFA GOOD
NIGHT'S SLEEP.
>> THANK YOU, JOHN.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
I'VE LOVED BONDING WITH YOU
ABOUT
I LOVE "NAMEME ABLE